when did you first
fall in love with the
dream of understanding sleep like
where did the fascination with sleep
begin
so back in the united kingdom you can
sort of start doing medicine at age 18
and it's a five-year program and i was
at the queen's medical center in the uk
and i remember just being fascinated by
states of consciousness and particularly
anesthesia
i think
isn't that within seconds i can take a
perfectly conscious human being
and i can remove all existence of the
mentality and their awareness within
seconds
and that stunned me so i started to get
really interested in conscious states i
even started to read a lot about
hypnosis
and all of these things hypnosis
even sleep and dreams at the time they
were very esoteric it was sort of
charlatan science at that stage
and i think almost all of my colleagues
and i are accidental sleep researchers
you know no one as i recall in the
classroom when you're sort of five years
old and the teacher says what would you
like to be when you grow up you know no
one's putting their hand up and saying i
would love to be a sleep researcher
and so when i was doing my phd
i was trying to
identify different forms of dementia
very early on in the course
and i was using electrical brainwave
recordings to do that and i was failing
miserably it was a disaster just no
result after no result
and i used to go home to the doctor's
residence with this sort of little igloo
of journals that at the weekend i would
sort of sit in and
uh and read and which i'm now thinking
do i really want to admit this because
it sounds like i had no social life
which i didn't i'm a social leper but
and i started to realize that some parts
of the brain were
um sleep related areas and
some dementias were eating away those
sleep related areas other dementias
would leave them untouched and i thought
well
i'm doing this all wrong i'm measuring
my patients while they're awake
instead i should be measuring them while
they're asleep
started doing that got some amazing
results
and then i wanted to ask the question is
that sleep um disruption that my
patients are experiencing as they go
into dementia maybe it's not a symptom
of the dementia i wonder if it's a cause
of
the dementia
and at that point which was
kafka 20 years ago
no one could answer a very simple
fundamental question why do we sleep
i at the time didn't realize that some
of the most brilliant minds in
scientific history had tried to answer
that question and failed
and at that point i just thought well
i'm going to go and do a couple of years
of sleep research and i'll figure out
why we sleep and then i'll come back to
my patients in this question of dementia
and as i said that was 20 years ago and
what i realized is that hard questions
care very little about who asks them
they will meter out their lessons of
difficulty all the same and i was
schooled
in the difficulty of the question why do
we sleep
but in truth 20 years later we've had to
upend the question
rather than saying why do we sleep and
by the way the answer then was
that we sleep to cure sleepiness
which is like saying all right you know
we eat to cure hunger that tells you
nothing about the physiological benefits
of food same with sleep
now we've actually have to ask the
question is there any physiological
system in the body or any major
operation of the mind that isn't
wonderfully enhanced when we get sleep
or demonstrably impaired when we don't
get enough
and so far for the most part the answer
seems to be now
so far the answer seems to be no
so
why
why does the body and the mind
crave sleep then why do we sleep
how yeah
can we begin to answer that question
then
so i think one of the ways that i think
about this or
one of the answers that came to me
is the following the reason that we
implode so quickly and so thoroughly
with insufficient sleep is because human
beings seem to be one of the few species
that will deliberately deprive
themselves of sleep for no apparent good
reason biological
and what that led me then to was the
following
mother nature as a consequence so
no other species does what we do in that
context there are a few species that do
undergo sleep deprivation but for very
obvious clear biological reasons one is
when they're in a condition of severe
starvation the second is when they're
caring for their newborn so for example
killer whales will often deprive
themselves the female will go away from
the pod
give birth and then bring the calf back
and during that time the mother will
undergo sleep deprivation and then the
the third one is during migration when
birds are flying trans oceanographic to
3 000 miles but for the most part it's
never seen in the animal kingdom
which brings me back to the point
therefore mother nature
in the course of evolution has never had
to face the challenge of this thing
called sleep deprivation
and therefore she has never created a
safety net in place
to
circumnavigate this common influence and
there's a good example where we have
which is called the adipose cell the fat
cell
because during our evolutionary past we
had famine and we had feast and mother
nature came up with a very clever recipe
which is
how can i store caloric
credit so that i can spend it when i go
into debt and the fat cell was born
brilliant idea where is the fat cell for
sleep
where is that sort of banking chip for
sleep and unfortunately we don't seem to
have one because she's never had to face
that challenge so even if there's not
some kind of physics
fundamental need for sleep
that uh physiologically or
psychologically the the fact is most
organisms are built such that they need
it and then mother nature
never built an extra mechanism for sleep
deprivation so it's interesting that why
we sleep by not have a good answer
but we need to sleep to be healthy
is nevertheless true
yeah we have many answers right now in
some ways the question of why we sleep
was the wrong question too
it's you know what are the pluripotent
many reasons we sleep we don't just
sleep for one reason
because
from an evolutionary perspective it is
the most idiotic thing that you could
imagine yeah you know when you're
sleeping you're not finding a mate
you're not reproducing you're not caring
for your young you're not foraging for
food and worse still you're vulnerable
to predation
so on any one of those grounds
especially as a collective sleep should
have been strongly selected against
in the course of evolution
but in every species that we've studied
carefully to date
sleep is present
yeah so it is important so like
you're right i think i've heard
arguments from an evolutionary biology
perspective that
sleep is actually advantageous
you know maybe like some kind of
predator prey relationships yeah but
you're saying
it actually makes way more sense what
is it should have been selected against
like why close your eyes
yeah why because and you know there was
an energy conservation hypothesis for a
while which is that we need to
essentially go into low battery mode you
know power down because it's
unsustainable but in fact that actually
has been blasted out the water because
sleep is an incredibly active process in
fact the difference between you just
lying on the couch but remaining
conscious versus you lying on the couch
and falling asleep it's only a savings
of about 140 150 calories in other words
you know you just go out and club
another baby seal or whatever it was and
you wouldn't worry you know so it has to
be much more to it than energy
conservation much more to it than
sharing you know ecosystem space and
time much more to it than simply
predator prey relationships
if sleep really did and you know looking
back even very old evolutionary
organisms like earthworms millions of
years old they have periods where
they're active in periods where they're
passively asleep it's called lethargicus
and so
what that
in some way suggested to me was
sleep evolved with life itself on it
this planet and then it has fought its
way through heroically every step along
the evolutionary pathway
which then leads to the
sort of famous um sleep statement from a
researcher that if sleep doesn't serve
an absolutely vital function or
functions then it's the biggest mistake
the evolutionary process has ever ever
made and we've now realized mother
nature didn't make a spectacular blunder
with sleep
you've mentioned the idea of conscious
states
do you think of sleep as a fundamentally
different conscious state than
awake
ness
and how many conscious states are there
so when you intuit your understanding
of what the mind can do do you think
awake state sleep state or is there some
kind of continuum
there's a complicated state transition
diagram like how do you think about this
whole space
i think about it as a state space
diagram and i think it's probably more
of a continuum than we have
believed it to be or suggested it to be
so we used to think
absent of anesthesia that there were
really three main main states of
consciousness there was being awake
being in non-rapid eye movement sleep or
non-dream sleep and then being in rapid
eye movement sleep would dream sleep and
those were the three states within which
your brain could
percolate and be conscious i you know
conscious during non-rem sleep is maybe
a stretch to say but i still believe
there is plenty of consciousness there
i don't believe that though anymore
and the reason is because we can have
daydreams
and we are in a very different wakeful
state in those day dreams than we are
when we are as we are now together
present and
extraceptively focused rather than
intraceptively focused
and then we also know that as you are
sort of progressing into those different
stages of sleep during non-rem sleep you
can also still dream depends on your
definition of dreaming but we seem to
have some degree of dreaming in almost
all stages of sleep
we've also then found that when you are
sleep deprived
there even individual brain cells will
fall asleep
despite the animal being
you know behaviorally from best we can
tell awake
individual brain cells and clusters of
brain cells will go into a sleep-like
state and humans do this too when we are
sleep deprived we have what are called
micro sleeps
where the eyelid will partially close
and the brain essentially falls lapses
into a state of sleep but behaviorally
you seem to be awake and the danger here
is road traffic accidents
so
these are the what we call these sort of
micro sleep events at the wheel now if
you're traveling at
65 miles an hour in a two ton vehicle
you know it takes probably around one
second to drift from one lane to the
next and it takes two seconds to go
completely off the road
so if you have one of these micro sleeps
at the wheel you know it could be the
last microsleep that you ever have
but i don't now see it as a set of you
know very binary distinct you know step
function state it's not a one or a zero
i see it more of a as a continuum
you